bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans le dpp du robot aujourd'hui nous
allons suivre le mari de la chaîne fait
de science du cnrs à votre avis ç'aurait
pu le relever le défi cooker à préparer
plongez au coeur de la robotique dans le
premier amour at war de robotique en
france vous pourrez en découvrir ses
secrets grâce aux scientifiques et leurs
robots et des maris dans sa quête
moutien dulas
de toulouse marie léger vrai et bon
c'est parti pour le plus sûr au monde
cet événement est organisé par le cnrs
en partenariat avec humilité bonjour
marie je suis me lis et je serai ton
guide aujourd'hui
là tu ne me connais pas mais moi j'étais
déjà vu plusieurs fois sur la chaîne la
pointe avec l'oeil aux hits et alors je
le serai là pour t'accompagner à travers
le défi futur os que les scientifiques
ont compté ou sans même d'uglas cnrs de
toulouse où tu te trouves trop bien
n'est ce pas tu es prêt à sucre est
c'est vrai alors petit rappel le conseil
pour le public
le détour robot c'est quoi c'est un jeu
de piste à la rencontre des robots
emblématique de la recherche de la
robotique en france et ses robots et les
scientifiques qui en sont à l'origine
vont te faire relever quelques défis
d'accord pour chaque défi tu ne recevra
une enveloppe puis tu devrais a trouvé
le rombo et les scientifiques sociaux et
là tu auras quelques minutes pour
échanger et l'expérimenté et découvrir
les spécificités du robot à la fin de l'
échange ils te donneront le défi et si
tu le réussis tu obtiendras une capsule
et le but c'est que tu collecte un max
de capsules ok c'est bon t'es pas trop
pressé mange froid
ok ça ce que tu n'es pas seul les
internautes qui sont en direct de
facebook et youtube seront là pourtant
vous ragez te donner des indices et télé
dans sa quête
et oui parce que la plupart du temps
vous chez vous nous aurez des énigmes à
fond donc depuis chez vous encourager
marie marie tête elle était peut-être un
petit message pour les encourager
accéder aux bennes n'hésitez pas à
réagir en live m'aider parce que c'est
un jeu de piste et donc peut-être que
j'aurai besoin d'un 10 vous n'hésitez
pas tout à fait il soyez bien attentifs
car à la fin vous pourrez participer à
un quiz et les dix premiers à répondre
correctement gagneront une surprise
est ce que tu es prête marc oui je suis
prêt ok alors juste avant de commencer
il me semble que antoine petit se trouve
à connais toi
il s'agit du président directeur général
du cnrs et elle a quelques mois à tenir
bonjour entame bonjour marie bienvenue
aulas donc là c'est un laboratoire du
cnrs 1 d'emile laboratoire du cnrs
mais ça laboratoire qui est spécialisé
dans des domaines auxquels on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui
alors c'est un domaine c'est un gros
laboratoire caen est plus grosse et des
rêves qui fait à la fois des micro et
nanotechnologies la pro matic de
l'automatique aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser à la robotique et donc tu
vas découvrir en cours de ton périple de
ton challandes je vais découvrir
quelques unes des facettes de la
robotique qui viennent du las mais pas
seulement parce qu'il faut savoir qu'une
vingtaine de laboratoires en france qui
travaille sur le domaine de la robotique
donc tu vas découvrir quelques-unes des
réalisations de ses laboratoires
alors tu vas découvrir de la robotique
humanoïde star qui ressemblent à des
humains animaleries qui ressemblent à
des animaux la robotique volantes mais
tu vois aussi avoir connaissance de
choses un peu transverses alors comment
est ce qu'un robot il interagit avec son
environnement
parce qu'évidemment c'est important si
on veut que les robots trouvent leur
place dans la société il faut qu'ils
soient capables d'interagir
donc tu vas découvrir tout ça alors tout
savoir c'est que ces laboratoires ils
sont très présents nouveau international
on est un pays qui compte sur la scène
internationale et j'en veux pour preuve
le fait que cette année en france ont
organisé on l été dernier me craquer la
grande conférence internationale de
robotique et puis en juin prochain en
juin 2021 on va organiser à bordeaux
n'ont pas de prix - la robocop qui est
une grande compétition aussi de roddick
alors tu vas voir que la robotique c'est
un domaine assez fascinant parce qu'en
fait ça fait appel à plein de sujets
alors bien sûr les matériaux passe il
faut construire ces robots tu verras il
ya des technologies modernes de
construire des robots
aux entraînements de 3b bien sûr ça fait
appel à l'informatique parce qu'il faut
il faut faire les logiciels qui vont
gouverner les robots des mathématiques
bien sûr mais des matériaux extraits des
matériaux nouveaux depuis tu verras
aussi que ça fait appel ou neuro
sciences aux sciences humaines et
sociales
parce qu'il faut interagir avec le roman
il faut que le robot nice a une passion
ils soient acceptées 6 à robben qui a
vocation à aller aussi vers le grand
public
tu vas découvrir tout ça et puis tu vas
découvrir si toutes les applications peu
à la robotique
c'est un domaine dans lequel on a
beaucoup d'interaction avec le milieu
industriel et par exemple parce qu'on
est à toulouse je ne peux pas ne pas
citer airbus qui est un des grands
partenaires du las mais tu découvriras
aussi d'autres entreprises de tailles
diverses avec lesquels on interagit et
puis tu vas voir que la robotique à
plein d'applications dans le domaine
médical dans le spatial dans les
transports tu vas découvrir tout ça
voilà quelques écoutes je souhaite bon
courage à mon premier du challenge
ça y est le biais quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important un mystérieux
merci antoine bon on découvre quand même
la première énigme ensemble on peut le
découvrir les jeunes je n'ai pas le
reste et bien moi je promis c'est parti
pour la première et dim
et oui il est possible de faire machine
arrière
allez avec keren que dans ces mouvements
que tu trouvera la réponse
je vais donc me diriger vers notre
premier défi merci antoine c'est parti à
ton avis
[Musique]
ouais
bonjour je suis marié enchanté voit ses
nuits enchantées mais moi j'avais olive
et génère donc vous avez été une bonne
introduction
voilà donc en fait on travaille sur la
génération de mouvement et donc là tu
vois un robot humanoïde qui s'appelle
pérenne et donc qui nous sert en fait à
étudier la génération de mouvement dont
la structure humaine et donc ça nous
permet à la fois de comprendre l'être
humain et décide générer des mouvements
alors la difficulté en fait c'est que le
robot à plein de ce qu'on appelle les
degrés de liberté sont les articulations
les moteurs dans le robot et d comment
s'appelle des sa position dans l'espace
donc la position en 3 dimensions donc
plus son orientation qui a trois
dimensions voile et comme tu peux le
constater
donc c'est un robot qui est compliqué
c'est un objet qui est assez complexe et
donc du coup on a des petits problèmes
comme ça d d c'est dommage parce qu'il
ya trente secondes il avait juste fait
le mouvement
donc je peux te montrer
[Musique]
il s'appelle selon donc si vous
connaissez un petit peu leurs beaux
spots munich de boston dynamics
il est un petit peu sur le même principe
du coup on est capable de conserver les
manipuler savant sur le robot on était
depuis il est disponible sur internet
donc si nous le disent et 14 vols
peuvent télécharger tous les plans site
est gratuit peuvent le modifier
ils se battront même pas mal de
possibilités donc ça ça nous permet avec
d'autres pilotes dans d'autres
universités de 15 de faire des
tentatives du mouvement sur ça veut dire
[Musique]
mais ça coûte un peu cher donc marie
échanges avec les scientifiques
responsables de pyrène je vous propose
d'en découvrir plus sur ce robot mais en
fait quand on a un robot humanoïde tout
est complexe
des actions qui paraissent évidents de
feyzin êtres humains se tenir debout
aller sur un terrain accidenté manipule
un tournevis c'est des choses qu'on fait
tous les jours de façon évidente sans
même y penser mais en fait ça nécessite
la coordination de tous ses muscles de
tout son squelette et c'est donc cela
qu'on essaie de reproduire avec notre
robot humanoïde pire est pour exécuter
ce mouvement là on est obligé de le
planifier et ensuite de les exécuter sur
le robot qui doit à ce moment là faire
des algorithmes qui vont adapter à la
situation le plan afin de pouvoir
accomplir sa tâche
donc le robot est un système
anthropomorphes c'est une version
simplifiée de l'humain l'humain donc
utilise ses muscles il à 200 degrés de
liberté le robot utilise ses moteurs il
en a 32 il utilise 32 degrés de liberté
+ 6 qui correspondent à sa position dans
le monde
donc ces moteurs sont situés dans ses
jambes dans ses bras dans son torse dans
sa tête et dans ses pinces la robotique
humanoïde
en plus d'être un défi intellectuel et
scientifique a un intérêt de par sa
morphologie
en effet car il est proche d'un être
humain il peut s'adapter à
l'environnement de notre monde et en
plus on peut l'utiliser dans des
endroits inaccessibles ou dangereux
aujourd'hui marie tu vas devoir trouver
le nombre de degrés de liberté de pyrène
nous les avons énoncé ati compter mari
comment ça se passe peut-être qu'on
c'est à vous montrer mais vous n'êtes
pas il ay là les gens qui sont souffle
donc quand elle va marcher il va
s'adapter à son environnement et on va
pouvoir le pousser et il va compter il
va garder son équilibre
ok merci les lignes pas entendu tout ça
oui j'ai entendu et marie je crois que
tu peux dire à nos avis et olivier que
c'est l'heure de ton premier défend
j'espère que j'ai bien écouté
alors on dit que c'est lors de mon
premier défi alors j'étais un peu
d'écrits oui bien est-ce que pire elle a
team de degrés de liberté pour lamah si
vous avez la réponse à la maison
n'hésitez pas à encourager mari n'est
pas un petite anglaise puisque les
téléspectateurs ont tendance à me
donnaient pour mes défauts le moment les
téléspectateurs de tout juste de
véhicules des encouragements 11
nos îles une petite aide oui alors je
t'ai parlé du nombre dans les bras du
nom dans la tête dans les jambes
chacune y en a 6 + 2 dans le torse pour
basculer et l'orientation et il y a donc
ce que donc obligé de parler après
précédemment pendant six degrés de
liberté pour sa position dans
l'environnement
donc ça fait faire un petit calcul si
simple de faire des liens que tu ça
laisse quatre ans le tout pour une
augmentation se tromper dans laquelle
temps qui nous a soufflé les réponses
sur internet il nous dit 32-32 plus la
position dans l'environnement qui fait
de 6,6 28 38
heureusement que les téléspectateurs
sont là pour m'aider mais oui la capsule
sakho bien fayet première capsule merci
d'avoir aidé le dollar
merci a eu de longues immersions et
nîmes
alors je vous met la pression pour
allier at-on deux oublis qui sur pied
gauche les chats à 8 rue que les
quelques photos ici ah oui quelqu'un on
apporte alors aujourd'hui je suis à
grenoble au gîte salhab ou un nouveau
défi robot m'attend et on va découvrir
ou est ce que je dois me rendre alors je
dois trouver une porte
ça n'a pas l'air d'être ici il ya une
petite pancarte avec écrit futurs robots
donc je pense que c'est la bonne porte
on va voir ça ensemble alors je découvre
une nouvelle pièce et je ne suis pas
seul mais une enveloppe juste ici que je
veux ouvrir et on va découvrir la
nouvelle énigme alors répond aux
questions de nina pour prendre son
contrôle et trouvent lundi
eh ben je vais m'installer justice y est
on va voir ce qui se passe
votre avis que l'appel devoir faire
bonjour bonjour on m'a programmé un
rendez vous avec marie c'est moi ah
super mari est ce que tu aimes les jeux
j'adore les jeux je perds aussi je te
propose qu'on fasse donc un jeu et ce
jour le fera trois avec gérard il
responsable de l'équipe crise pour
attendre que gérard arrivent
voilà gérable bonjour marie bonjour
ninon a donc alain sinon ben je vais
conclure et bien moi nina nina gérard je
te laisse te présenter moi je suis jarre
vallier directeur de recherche au cnrs
voilà qu'on a on anime cette cette
activité trop politique sociale avec
frédéric
lisez leaké ingénieur de recherche à dix
s'occupe de cette cet environnement
superbe et avec mina et ben bella
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire ce que
vous êtes prêt à jouer avec moi oui bien
sûr donc je vais vous expliquer les
règles de ce jeu
donc ce jeu s'appelle ou une animaux je
vais vous donner un thème ce thème a
déjà été donnée à des joueurs qui sont
sur internet et ils ont donné une liste
de mots auxquels ces thèmes leur faisait
penser donc le jeu pour vous ça va être
de trouver les meilleurs mots qui ont
été cités sur internet par les joueurs
très bien donc c'est un jeu en équipe
vous devez tombés d'accord sur quelle
mouche vous me proposez bonjour sans
proposer un mot pour le chien dont celui
ci fait partie des huit meilleurs mots
les plus cités il vous fait une deuxième
proposition une troisième proposition et
on change de tête super que ça me semble
clair c'est parfait donc je vous donne
un exemple si le thème était crevettes
peut-être que vous pourriez penser à
rose ou grises ou crustacés ou gambas et
me faire une proposition en ce sens très
bien vous êtes prêt pour jouer avec moi
oui
gérard aussi cheminement donc pour notre
premier thème nous allons jouer un mec
robotique robotique alors robotique ça
peut nous faire penser à informatique
par exemple je suis pour le probable
voilà ma rue premier le new area léon
proposant un maximum en un clic
effectivement informatique est une très
bonne réponse
elle fait partie des huit premières
super idée de thèmes est ce que parce
qu'il permet d'explorer en fait
interactions sociales homme robot dans
ce qu'on appelle à distance
interpersonnelles c'est à dire entre 50
cm et 1 mètre 50 typiquement lorsqu'on
est chaque côté d'une table
son but un autre but c'est d'avoir ces
interactions le plus naturel possible
alors pour interagir en fait nina
utilise évidemment
le langage verbal si on utilise aussi le
langage non verbal tout ce qui aide les
mains pour bâtir son discours le regard
du mouvement de tête des expressions
faciales et en fait ce langage non
verbal il est extrêmement important
parce qu'il permet d'indiquer à autrui à
qui on s'adresse ce que je m'adresse à
vous et ce que je m'adresse à marie ou
est ce que me dresse à quelqu'un d'autre
ça permet aussi d'exprimer des
informations complémentaires comme la
taille des choses comme indiqué des
objets d'intérêt dans l'espace de
travail commun notre ambition c'est de
rendre l'interaction entre l'homme et le
robot le plus symétrique possible donc
tout le monde a dans l'idée que
l'intelligence artificielle permet de
capturer de d'analyser les états mentaux
les gens ce qui nous intéresse nous
c'est que en symétrie les gens puissent
lire ce que font les robots eux d'avoir
une relation réciproque qui en fait
créer un climat de confiance entre les
deux interlocuteurs ces comportements
verbaux et non verbaux en fait ils
dépendent de la tâche est donc l'idée
c'est que les personnes qui étaient au
père robots donc ils démontrent les
comportements sociaux qui sont adéquats
ce sont en fait des professionnels de la
tâche quand on aide les gens à faire une
recette de cuisine ça doit être un
cuisiner quand nina on lui apprend à
faire des tests neuro psycho et bien
c'est une neuropsychologue qui s'en
occupe
cette prise en main par le professionnel
va être très intuitive donc l'idée c'est
déjà prendre part démonstration donc on
va lui fournir des exemples qui marche
avec son corps des exemples qui viennent
des humains qui ont l'habitude de ces
situations qui savent s'adapter qui
savent gérer des enfants des adultes et
grâce à la telle opération on est dans
le corps de nina on perçoit comme nina
ni plus vite ni avec une meilleure
résolution on entend comme ina donc les
solutions qu'on trouve avec notre
cerveau humain c'est des bonnes
solutions du point de vue des humains et
cd bonne solution pour le robot puisque
elle s'exécute sur le robot quelque part
on lui fait un don cognitifs de comment
résoudre ce problème d'interaction ou
d'autres types de problèmes donc on est
vraiment sûr et à l'opération immersive
les efforts que je vais faire pour
regarder près ou loin li na va faire
exactement la même chose donc je me
retrouve
du point de vue du contrôle des yeux du
point de vue du contrôle du coût mais
aussi de ma perception audio de la salle
avec des capacités qui sont extrêmement
proches des miennes c'est ça qui fait
qu'on va pouvoir piloter minasse sans
avoir à apprendre comment faire donc
c'est grâce à ces marqueurs notamment
qu'on peut capturer mon articulation et
la reproduire sur nina bonjour je suis
et d'ailleurs c'est comme ça que par les
yeux du robot que marie va avoir une
révélation du défi de la l'objet qu'elle
veut récupérer du pilote c'est qu'elle
est pilotée en fait part par un humain
mais les normands qui lui apprend en
fait à se comporter de manière
socialement acceptable dans une
situation comme ça d'interaction avec
les humains donc est ce qu'on appelle
aux céréales fait de l'apprentissage par
démonstration d'accord donc l'humain il
est pas très loin dans la classe à côté
mais à quelqu'un qui est caché je le
sens présentée bravo marie tu as
effectivement compris qu il y avait une
astuce
donc je vais vous inviter à venir voir
l'envers du décor ou et qu'effectivement
juste derrière vous derrière la vitre
sans tain donc il ya le pilote du robot
2001 donc en l'occurrence frédéric
l'elysée on verra a parlé tout à l'heure
vous pouvez venir me rejoindre
maintenant dans la salle et vous verrez
comment j'arrive à piloter le robot et
je te proposerait de prendre ma place
pour la suite de ton henning whaou
j'ai super hâte de voir ça on va voir
frédéric rose le père s'est ménagée
regard tout chaud ça tu saisis et la
découverte et réopéré mineurs va-t-elle
encore découvrir notre mari l eau vous
aimez les robots oui j'aime les robots
j'aime bien les humains
alors je vous voyais un vent vient le
robot je vais pouvoir enlever mon casque
bonjour avec laquelle vous entendez en
stéréo mon casque avec lequel je vous
voyais un stéréo
je vais pouvoir mettre mon masque vous
avez vu les marqueurs grâce auquel nina
pouvait reproduire
bush et ça va être votre tour
je vais essayer le temps de désinfecter
le matériel et ce sera au tour j'ai trop
hâte alors frédéric maintenant que je
suis bien installé est ce que tu peux
m'expliquer comment tu vas me
transformer en nina bien sûr marie je
vois que tu as déjà installé les
microphones bravo gvt dès maintenant
installé le casque oui pour que tu
puisse voir en stéréo ce que ce qui est
filmé par les caméras de nina il
commandait ses yeux c'est grâce à l'eau
km qui est dedans pour fixer le cas je
vais te demander de le lâcher ta queue
de cheval
c'est donc d'installer sa directement
sur tourner s'il te plait je vais le
serré derrière puisque c'est le bon
réglage
ça me semble parfait tient tout seul
c'est bon parfait mari oui donc là je
vais te on va apprendre en fait comment
tu regardes donc pour que la machine
soit capable d'analyser en temps réel
d'accord c'est fou disque puisque tu
regardes et piloter du coup les jeux de
2001 donc on va devoir faire une petite
séquence d'entraînement où tu vas suivre
un motif sur sur l'écran donc là je vois
des petites croix verte et là un espèce
de quadrillage avec des poules grille
donc je vais te demander de regarder le
point du milieu et on va suivre ce point
là on va vérifier la précision je te
laisse aller en haut à gauche en haut à
droite en bas à droite en bas à gauche
ça visiblement commencé à partir du
point du centre s'il te plaît donc en
fait c'est fou parce que quand je bouge
mes yeux le point su en fait donc la
machine c'est exactement tu regardes tu
as fait ça pour chacun de tes yeux
indépendamment donc en bas à droite s'il
te plaît très bien on va faire avec ça
ça a l'air correct aux mots si je le
souhaite je suis très très bon donc là
je vais commencer par te connecter avec
ce que voient les caméras du robot je
vais faire ce que tu confirmes que tu
vois la salle de bain oui entre autres
tu dois tu dois revoir ton reflet dans
le miroir qui en face de toi je suis
vraiment li na la suite faut la situer
dans le corps donne une âme et une
commande de rien la sarthe les
spectateurs dans le cordonnier à l'étape
d'après ça va être que j'active là bas
les moteurs et que le robot suivent les
mouvements à la fois les mouvements des
yeux
est-ce que tu regardes presse que tu
regardes loin à droite à gauche en haut
en bas et aussi des mouvements de la
tête encore donc pour cette manip là on
ne pilotera pas les lèvres du robot oui
comme comme je pouvais faire moi ce que
tu n'en as pas besoin pour trouver ton
indice à a donc là je vois vraiment la
pièce où j'étais tout à l'heure tu peux
mettre le casque audio
tiens bon tu entends leçon de là bas
est-ce que tu ensemble du son qui vient
de là bas est ce que tu entends parler
oui c'est bon il est ce que tu entends
parler oui c'est parfait donc je veux
aller activer le robot donc ne bouge pas
la tête tu me vois gt va les jeux tu
entends c'est parfait nous aussi on vous
voit donc ne bouge toujours pas
3 2 tu peux bouger les yeux doucement
oui on voit l' enfer tu peux vous jurer
d'être doucement et je te laisse
chercher ton indices c'est complètement
fou ce qui est en train de se passer
alors ville en carte devant moi une
pancarte avec un signe en noir et blanc
donc il va avoir besoin d'une souris
qu'on va te donner du momentum glisser
sous la main ok désolé pour les pieux
je n'hésite pas à bouger ta tête et à
bouger tes yeux voilà comme tu le ferais
avec ta vraie tête
aussi est ce que tu vois c'est
complètement fou donc là je suis dans le
minas je vois même ses mains et je vois
vraiment la salle dans laquelle j'étais
tout à l'heure c'est complètement fou
alors est-ce que tu as trouvé la capsule
indice est ce que tu as trouvé l'argent
mais juste un panneau avec un cygne noir
et blanc il y avait quelque chose
d'écrit tout à l'heure elle a trouvé
d'accord donc là j'ai un petit panneau
qui s'est affichée avec écrit besoin des
aides pour la capsule indices cliquez
ici et je peux cliquer dessus
oui clic la capsule indices et elle
visible dans la salle à droite ou à
gauche et va la trouver
salut public
pour l'instant je ne vois pas la capsule
elle est bien cachée la capsule indices
étaient visibles en hauteur mais où tu
te cache pas si facile c'est défini
d'enghien s'est-elle dans une des mains
du robot je ne vois rien dans les mains
du robot
si on atteint là non plus
elle doit être sue ce panneau oui c'est
vrai que le sida dont 6 août le débit
d'un bon à dire une fois le site et vous
pourrez venir la récupérer
et oui bravo bravo et bravo tu sait
piloter langot sans avoir passé de
formation préalable
sata semblait facile de piloter leur ont
baissé assez intuitif ouais c'est les
mouvements tes yeux les mouvements de la
tête ça fait bizarre
est-ce que tu as eu l'impression de
changer de corps est ce que tu as eu
l'impression de changer de perception
mais vraiment oui tu étais la coque du d
ici un an j'étais là bas j'étais là-bas
évidemment avec le sont pas je sens le
sens il est vraiment stéréo il est mieux
que stéréo en fait parce qu'il ya des
pavillons aux oreilles du robot donc on
a vraiment cette impression que les sons
se déplace ou que quand on tourne
laissons nous suivent ce fait c'est
mieux que la stéréo et ça c'est grâce au
pavillon qui sont sur les oreilles
attention ton micro connaître les micros
je suis un peu pressé d'aller chercher
j'imagine bien et nourrit les pressions
va aller chercher cette capsule se
trouve sous le panneau
alors on va découvrir cette recette
capsule qui doit se trouver ça ici et
voilà trouvé c'est bon on a la capsule
bravo merci frédéric merci tournai à
lille
merci mina nous on va se retrouver tout
de suite à toulouse pour la suite des
aventures en tout cas c'était un super
moment plein de découvertes et j'ai hâte
de voir la suite
coucou harry n
et oui en fait le deuxième défi il était
pas 12 mais maintenant nous sommes de
retour et je vois que tu as quelqu'un en
face de devoir nous fait même oublier
jurt la droite a je crois que je suis
attendu c'est un projet qui les
palanganas une petite enveloppe
incroyable il joue alors sur l'onglet on
va découvrir cette première
anim'ensemble berenson est un amateur
d'art et son sens artistique
il ne l'a pas développer n'importe où
j'imagine que c'est lui qui il dira and
sun et je crois que je suis attendu
bonjour je viens berenson plus tard oui
exactement
monkey et berenson berenson c'est de
trop beau amateur doit être capable de
faire plein de choses qui est capable de
produire des expressions faciales
d'analyser son environnement
les yeux pour voir ici évidemment être
capable de bouger dans tout l'espace
qu'on a ici et nous on m'a fait des
expériences au musée d'accord l'idée de
l'expérience assez simple c'est que
l'art au musée il va y avoir des des
visiteurs est ce qu'on veut c'est que
les visiteurs puissent transmettre des
valences émotionnel visa sur les oeuvres
d'art et le robot il va apprendre le
fait que par exemple cette oeuvre d'art
va être plutôt négative
donc il apprend très rapidement donc
c'est un apprentissage autonome est ce
qu'on appelle robotique un an quand
jacques incrémentale et on voit là une
oeuvre d'art qui l'a appris je me semble
ça donne négativement avec sa bouche
fait une expression plutôt négative mais
il n'est pas content il n'est pas
content de ce qu'il a enfin bras parce
qu'il a il a appris à ne pas aimer cette
oeuvre c'était bien donc il est capable
de savoir si entre guillemets mais mon
pote l'hexagone oeuvres qu'il entend
assez contre la peau mais alors comment
on peut arriver mais ne pas aimer
quelque chose à l'idée c'est qu'on a mis
en réseau neuronal à tort de entre
guillemets de son cerveau artificiel
si vous voulez on peut juste aller là
bas et voir un petit peu j'étais sûr sur
l'écran on fit philippe cossy il va vous
expliquer un peu comment ça on voit ce
que voit berenson
en fait il a un système de visites de
vision et donc petit à petit en fait il
fait un certain nombre de saccades sur
sur la scène est globalement bas chacune
de ces choses là il a appris à les
associer comme étant quelque chose de
positif ou négatif
si on vient sur l'autre objet en fait
globalement va voir que dans ce cas là
normalement il ya appris autre chose
pour pour cet objet là
et donc voilà donc après et alors et
quand il m'aime ils nous regardent il
peut généraliser c'est dire bombesque on
ressemble plus à des objets qu'il aime
bien on objets qu'ils n'aiment pas voilà
donc si on est sûr celui là là
normalement
voilà
il est prête à temps oui exactement
alors j'entends de me poser une question
il avance tout seul il n'est pas pilotée
alors cette ça dépend des cas pour aller
plus vite
globalement rendez sur un mode où il est
où les piloter mais dans le musée l'idée
c'est que ils se baladent vraiment tout
seul et il explore le musée il va vers
les objets entre guillemets qui lui
plaisent bien
et voilà est amour et essaye juste de
découvrir le musée donc il faut
comprendre c'est que les expériences
qu'on a fait avec berenson c'est surtout
pour essayer aussi de comprendre comment
développe nos capacités d'interaction
qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment à la
base qu'est ce qu'on a besoin de minimal
pour pouvoir interagir avec une machine
et notamment s'est rendu compte que même
avec une tête expressif qui est très
simple et bien on peut mimer ses
expressions et globalement entre
guillemets être en sympathie un petit
peu avec ce type de robot
y'a vraiment pas besoin que ce soit un
système qui soit complexe pour le faire
et notamment toutes les expériences au
musée donc on a fait avec denis vidal
qui est ethnologue nous ont montré que
par l'ampleur même quand on explique aux
gens me voyaient là ce robot ils n'en
ont pas ils ne parlent pas mais malgré
le fait qu'ils n'entendent pas et qu'il
ne parle pas eh bien il peut déjà
interagir avec nous on peut comprendre
un petit peu voilà qu'est ce qu'il vous
regarde voilà l'enjeu parce qu'il
ressemble effectivement voilà on a une
idée de qu'est ce qui se passe entre
guillemets dans une danse dans ses
salles bloqué mais alors je rebondis sur
ce que j'en pense que j'ai utilisé le
mot ressentir puisque c'est tentant la
grande question est ce que vraiment
vraiment sensible a en ce sens de
l'esthétique
alors qu'on a fait c'est que globalement
il y une autre idée en fait d'une part
on se pose des questions de savoir
qu'est ce qu'il fait notre sens
esthétique doudou est ce que nous est ce
que ça vient et dans le musée en fait
d'une part on voulait questionner les
visiteurs là dessus nous berenson cegla
clairement le goût des autres c'est à
dire que il interagit avec plein de
visiteurs les visiteurs lui dise ah bah
ça j'aime bien ça j'aime pas et en
fonction de sa berenson finalement
moyenne un petit peu le bout des
différents visiteurs mais ça permet aux
visiteurs de se questionner sur leur
sens esthétique
et puis ça permettait aussi aux gens du
musée en fait de pouvoir questionner les
visiteurs sur méo cet objet lave est ce
que vous savez de quoi il s'agit vous
êtes en train de me reposer vous avez
mis vos en musée ont mis des visiteurs
en effet sa pudeur année d'affilée
comment les visiteurs réagissent moi
demain je suis dans un musée jeunes aux
ballades et là je tombe sur berenson
d'ailleurs ces salaires la surprise ça a
été que les gens prêtent des intentions
à berenson qui sont très largement au
delà des algorithmes que nous on utilise
et donc ça ça nous questionnent sur
justement entre humains qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on prête des intentions à un
autre humain qu'est ce qui permet un
bébé de se développer et nous notre
notre hypothèse de base c'est vraiment
de se dire en fait ce qui est important
c'est au départ les interactions
émotionnel et qu'à partir des
interactions émotionnel et bien le bébé
va se constituer un répertoire entre
guillemets des interactions de plus en
plus complet j'ai une petite question
bonus qui me vient à l'esprit pourquoi
mais rennes seule fois seulement alors
fait danser avec deux c'est denis vidal
qui avait proposé ce nom-là berenson
était
un critique d'art en fait de la fin du
19e siècle
et voilà et qui s'intéressait beaucoup
aux impressionnistes donc voila c'était
aussi une sorte de boutade en même temps
par rapport à un certain à une certaine
manière entre 10 mai de voir
l'esthétique et voilà que j'étais le
pouvoir discussion là dessus
ce chapeau melon la modélisation corbeau
dans nos expériences en général être
utilisé comme un outil pour cette
comprendre le développement du bio est
ce qu'on essaie de comprendre finalement
c'est comment est ce qu'un enfant il va
être capable de se développer de manière
autonome sans forcément mettent
énormément d'à priori dans les systèmes
donc ces personnes utilisent des réseaux
de neurones pour miner entre guillemets
des cerveaux qui vont êtres artificiels
et c'est demain voilà d'avoir des
dialogues avec des psychologues des
neurobiologistes en fait des gens qui
font des neurosciences pour faire
avancer un petit peu les aspects de
compréhension et continuer à échanger
autour de berenson et pendant que le
mari découvre les facettes cachées
nous aussi faisons de même de notre côté
en pratique
en fait nous on essaie de développer des
modèles de réseaux de neurones les plus
simples possibles qui soit capable
d'expliquer certains types de
comportements donc là on a vu berenson
qu'ils étaient en train de réagir à un
certain nombre d'objets qu'ils avaient
appris ou dans notre cas il est en train
de généraliser sur d'autres objets ce
qu'il avait pu apprendre donc les
valeurs soient positives ou négatives de
ces objets donc nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de comprendre les
processus du développement
donc on essaye d'abord de comprendre
comment est ce que les les bébés font
pour apprendre à interagir dans leur
environnement à reconnaître un certain
nombre d'objets les premières choses
qu'on a appris à notre robot ça a été à
reconnaître les expressions faciales des
gens qui étaient autour de lui puis
après en fait on a exploité le fait
qu'il le pouvait reconnaître quand on
est en train de sourire que c'était un
sourire pour associer cette valence
positive cette valeur positive à un
objet qui était a priori neutre pour
notre robot et donc on peut après avoir
notre robot qui va se diriger vers des
hommes
et qu'il considère comme étant positif
on va éviter des objets qui serait
négatif en fait les expériences qu'on a
faits au musée elle avait des débuts qui
était assez différents les uns des
autres pour nous je dirais ingénieurs
notre but c'était de tester la capacité
du robot déjà reconnaître des objets
correctement dans la dans
l'environnement dans un environnement
amusé c'était aussi de pouvoir vérifier
dans quelle mesure est ce que le
comportement de notre robot était
lisible des visiteurs est ce qu'un
visiteur qui entre 1 voilà tu y croies
notre robot peut se rendre compte que
notre robot apprécié entre guillemets
certaines oeuvres ou au contraire
n'aimerais pas d'autres oeuvres le côté
après plus sur le versant être nos logis
donc là c'est des travaux que l'on a
fait avec denis vidal donc il ya de nos
blogs
c'était plus de se demander pourquoi
dans certains cas on va percevoir entre
guillemets un robot comme étant une
personne
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui est
important ou pas pour que finalement
personnifier un robot et pourquoi les
gens vont lui prêter des intentions qui
ne correspondent absolument pas à ce
qu'il est capable de faire donc par
exemple on avait beaucoup de gens au
musée qui alors qu'on avait expliqué à
ces personnes que notre robot un
entendez parce qu'on disait n'avait pas
entre guillemets d'oreilles et bien
malgré tout ils disaient à leurs enfants
lorsqu'ils quittent et berenson dit au
revoir aux robots et donc pourquoi dans
certains cas justement dans cet aspect
de socialisation du robot
comment est-ce qu'on l'intègre dans nos
interactions et dans quelle mesure est
ce que le fait qu'on ait ce genre de
comportement social avec notre robot va
même pouvoir l'aider à apprendre un
certain nombre de choses l'apport de la
robotique ça a été d'une part de montrer
que effectivement ça pouvait tourner que
ça fonctionnait en live les surprises
qu'on a eue au musée ça a été de se
rendre compte aussi 2 à quel point les
gens apprécient entre guillemets
interagir avec le robot dans la mesure
où le robot réagissez à leur présence le
défi de marie sera de trouver dans quel
musée nous avons fait les expériences
avec le robot berenson vous l'avez
compris le cas je recherche
c'est un ski féminin qui va permettre
aux enfants
oui c'est antoine permettre de
reconnaître des faits super tu es allé
même coup kelly renson mois et coûte
c'est vrai que je préfère ce petit ange
doré que le squelette mais bon j'aime
bien les deux mains mais je pense que
berenson et moi on est d'accord il est
symbolique et sociale et vie bon défi
pour toi apparemment vous avez un défi à
me lancer j'ai hâte de voir ça donc la
question c'est de savoir dans quel musée
parisien
elle a pu faire les expériences avec le
robot berenson les internautes ont eu
bien raison a donc les internautes
savent déjà mais donnez moi des indices
et des mois alors une petite piste
qu'est ce que c'est un musée
d'art moderne alors pas du tout pas du
tout bon alors je vais prendre
complètement l'opposé c'est un musée
très historique
oui à beaucoup d'aspects historique la
crise thèmes principaux
voilà c est ce que c'est un musée par
exemple qui nous propose que de l'art
sur un seul artiste ou un seul secteur
du tout n'aurait pas forcément
d'ailleurs des choses qui sont vues
uniquement sous un angle artistique
c'est descend donc ça peut il ya un
aspect un petit peu culturel les
maritimes
j'ai une petite fille mais je ne peux et
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai entendu quelques
nuages et le musée du quai branly je vis
aussi grave on a trop bien
j'ai gagné la capsule mais si regardez
la prière merci bell and fun et pour le
prochain et qui là aussi on va voyager
hors de toulouse direction la capitale
où tu as pris part à une compétition
unique en son genre
marie alors oui tu pilotes ans et je
suis aujourd'hui au campus pierre et
marie curie à sorbonne universités où
j'ai rendez vous à lire pour mon
prochain défi robot j'ai hâte de
découvrir ça et je crois que là bas il
ya une petite enveloppe qui m'attend
venez on va regarder ça ensemble
alors
saha participe aussi bat long et
remporte ton épreuve
eh bien je ne sais pas ce que c'est
qu'un sibat longue on va découvrir son
ensemble juste derrière cette partie
mais quel est ce nouvel endroit
complètement mystérieux en tout cas
c'est super vaste j'ai hâte de voir ce
qui m'attend un petit peu en tout cas
j'ai l'impression que deux personnes
selon la bon jour marine bonjour je suis
nathanaël poissy charlotte un chanteur
hayon à l'institut des systèmes
intelligents et de robotique de son
université et vous êtes ici dans la
salle dans laquelle on s'entraîne pour
la compétition du sibat long qui aura
lieu en novembre 2020 ok qu'est ce que
c'est que le sibat l'ont alors le siba
lyon c'est une compétition
internationale qui a lieu tous les
quatre ans un peu comme les jeux
olympiques mais qui est bédié à des
personnes avec un handicap
équipés de technologie active
contrairement aux jeux paralympiques
dans le cas qui nous intéresse des
prothèses deux membres supérieurs de
bras mais ça peut être des prothèses de
jambes des exosquelettes des
autocollants d'accord et finalement
quels sont les enjeux de cette
compétition du corps alors les enjeux
c'est les personnes ne vont pas faire
une épreuve sportive au centre ne pas
faire de l'athlétisme ne vont pas courir
mais ça sera plus des épreuves de la vie
quotidienne pour montrer à quel point
c'est difficile quand on a appareillé de
faire toutes ces épreuves et que ça
devient vite une compétition sportive
c'est aussi l'occasion de montrer tous
les développements qui sont faits soit
par les entreprises privées soit par les
universités comme hockey est donc en
fait finalement ce que vous êtes en
train de me dire c'est que vous
travaillez sur des gestes du quotidien
qui peut être nous nous semble
finalement hyper simple mais qui peuvent
devenir finalement aussi quelque chose
de accès compétition parce que c'est un
vrai challenge en fait de vivre avec une
prothèse finalement oui exactement
notre approche au laboratoire c'est de
développer des nouvelles des nouveaux
modes de contrôle qui soit plus intuitif
et plus simple à utiliser pour la
personne et donc on essaye de les mettre
en oeuvre notamment à travers les
épreuves du sidaction
quels types d'exercices peuvent faire
ces personnes du coup pour s'entraîner
par exemple alors je te montrer les
écrans glossy bachelot vient par exemple
ah oui il indiqué va empiler des
gobelets pour en faire une pyramide donc
comme ça ouais vraiment prendre
retourner le gobelet lui ça c'est
fastoche ok il faut faire des pyramides
et pour toi ça peut paraître simple mais
par exemple quelqu'un qui a une prothèse
va d'abord retourner le gobelet puis le
prendre d'une autre façon avant de les
poser comme il ya soit henry ok mais en
fait ça nous semble très simple mais ça
soulève beaucoup de questions par
exemple moi je sais que si là je vais
prendre ce gobelet je vais sentir de la
matière etc
mais ces personnes là doivent gérer un
tas de choses finalement il ya une vraie
perte des sens donc c'est un challenge
assez énorme finalement exactement toi
quand tu prends un gobelet tu vas sentir
situe le cers tout le tire d'ailleurs
paris glisse mais avec la prothèse tu
n'as pas du tout ce retour et tu ne le
sentira pas tu risque de laisser tomber
le gobelet sans le savoir parce que tu
vas pas cessé d'accord et qu'est-ce
qu'on a par ici par ici on a quelque
chose beaucoup plus de la vie
quotidienne risquer sa lessive donc ça
peut être mettre une pince a lancé par
es salaam beaucoup de précision faire
ses lacets mettre son pull
si on donnait une baisse la mettre sur
un cintre lui toutes ces petites choses
qui nous paraissent très facile et qui
viennent des vrai challenge incroyable
et même d'autres actions auxquelles on
ne pense pas des petits objets comme
accroché ses clés quand on rentre à la
maison ou brancher une clé usb
les choix on a déjà du mal nous mêmes à
mettre la clé usb alors imagine avec une
prothèse
- gm est toujours dans les sciences un
pli sent pas comment se rentrer mais ça
demande beaucoup de temps en fait c'est
des gestes du quotidien mais qui demande
un pas de deux
de réflexes et aussi beaucoup de
précision finalement dans notre
quotidien
donc là qu'est ce qu'on attend c'est
prendre un stylo par exemple pour le
mettre dans son pot à crayons pour
d'accord j'ai un dvd dans cet espace un
emplacement bombe à carros est vraiment
tous les gestes du quotidien prendre sa
carte au parti wafd a pris la carte
comme ça ouais parce que tu as un
mouvement que souvent et les gens avec
une prothèse ne peuvent pas faire mais
avec une prothèse ils vont faire ils
vont la mener au bord de la table et
l'attrapé comme ça pour d'un abandon et
des détours en fait la nature dans le
génie qui a trouvé super est ce qu'on va
jouer aujourd'hui on va voir les
dernières épreuves qui est trop bien
faire ok alors qu'est ce que c'est alors
le but c'est de déplacer cet anneau
autour du fil de fer sans la toucher
s'ils saluent sa purge est équipé d'une
prothèse qui à un poignet et demain ok
on va contrôler le poignet donc
mouvement a vraiment que deux poignets
j'ai beaucoup droite et donc là dans un
premier temps c'est que vous allez
utiliser les boutons voiliers qui
symbolise le fondement qui symbolise le
fonctionnement d'une prothèse classiques
comme ce qui est vendu dans le commerce
ou la personne normalement doit faire
des contractions dans une action
volontaire pour père tourner le poignet
là tu peux le faire avec des boutons
donc un peu comme un petit joystick de
consoles de jeux vidéo si je touche à
gauche ça va à gauche c'est ça ok et si
je vais à droite ça tourne à droite et
donc il y avait vraiment des prothèses
qui fonctionne comme ça aujourd'hui ça
doit être hyper compliqué à gérer en
fait donc vous vous apporter des
solutions j'imagine différentes à tout
ça il ya vraiment des prothèses qui ont
ça c'est d'ailleurs toutes les prothèses
qui sont vendus est remboursé par la
sécurité sociale ont ce principe de
contraction donc imagine plus c'est pas
intuitif son biceps triceps pour
contrôler pas main par exemple marie
logique
nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on essaye de
donner des approches plus intuitif plus
simple pour l'utilisateur et notamment
une approche qui est basée sur les
mouvements ton corps et ça va être
beaucoup plus plongé allez donc là je
sois lèvres soulève un peu il faut que
la classique avec des boutons qui
représente ce que doit faire une
personne amputée la vie courante voilà
il faut anticiper il faut faire une
commande et son corps et la prothèse
c'est une certaine gymnastique qui
réfléchissent à maturation
c'est pas du tout facile en plus le
poids est quand même assez important
l'important c'est pas du tout facile on
a pas de tortures et très longtemps on
va te faire essayer en fait surtout les
approches de contrôle que charlotte a
explosé juste un instant hockey qui
utilisent des mouvements du corps donc
si tu veux repartir en position initiale
on va faire essayer une approche
innovante qu'on a développé au
laboratoire j'ai hâte de voir ça parce
que pour l'instant c'est quand même
hyper complexe
parmi eux il faut que tu te redresse un
peu et que ce soit dans une position un
peu comportant leurs fouets pour moi le
plus important c'est parti ça tu es
prête alors ah oui d'accord donc ça n'a
rien à voir je ne touche pas du tout
ouais pas lui tenant comme j'essaie de
comprendre
donc en fait là on a l'impression que la
prothèse sens en fait anticipé mon
mouvement c'est complètement faux qui il
fit n'a pu utiliser les boutons
tu n'es pas en train volontairement deux
contres de contrôler l'action elle
s'adapte à ou mouvements de ton corps ça
demande une certaine certaines
adaptations notamment il ya un petit
délai mais très rapidement tu vas te
couple et la prothèse à ce couple et se
coordonner à tj sata gestuelle jeu
complètement concentré là
mais parce que quand on voit ça on se
dit que c'est facile mais c'est hyper
complexe mais du coup c'est vrai que là
cette approche là sans le petit joystick
est vachement plus en cultive donc là je
c'est dingue j'ai vraiment l'impression
de travailler avec la prothèse au lieu
d'avoir réfléchir à la contrôler
oui c'était pas un retour vous êtes dur
avec moi mais là du coup ça elle a un
petit peu en fait finalement le coup de
manche prend assez rapidement pour
l'instant j'ai pas encore touché où il
va falloir que tu t'entraînes parce que
l'objectif de 2 tackett ça va être
d'affronter notre pilote pour le sibac
lyon christophe qui sera équipé de sa
prothèse avait réalisé la même épreuve
donc là c'est pas mon épreuve finale en
fait donc moi je me suis dit c'est bon
ça y est c'est fini
adacore donc c'est un entraînement pour
un défi tout à fait et va j'ai hâte de
voir ça parce que j'adore caymaris
entraîner des composants plus sur cette
prothèse robotisée pas trop bien nous
sommes ici dans une salle dans laquelle
se tiendra le 6 bat longue et une
compétition sportive internationale pour
les personnes en situation d'handicap
c'est une compétition qui devait avoir
lieu à zurich en mai 2020 et suite au
confinement a été reportée en novembre
et se tiendra localement dans chaque
université participantes donc dans cette
salle il va y avoir une épreuve du
sidaction pour les personnes amputées de
bras équipé de prothèses deux membres
supérieurs robotisés concernant les
prothèses de membres faut savoir que
finalement il ya eu ces dernières années
un grand développement technologique
avec des prothèses de plus en plus
sophistiquées mais en parallèle de ce
développement important de la
mécatronique les possibilités de
contrôler ces dispositifs de ressentir
au travers n'ont eu que très peu évolué
ces trente dernières années une prothèse
même dit bionique
elle se contrôler en général d'une façon
qu'on appelle millions électrique
c'est à dire qu'on va utiliser des
contractions musculaires de type un peu
code morse pour envoyer des ordres aux
articulations de la prothèse pour voir
la moue voire un exemple une personne
amputée par exemple de bras va utiliser
des contractions de son biceps pour
envoyer un ordre de fermer la main du
triceps pour ouvrir la main résultat la
prothèse sophistiquée elle est
esthétiquement très avancée mais elle se
contrôler articulation par articulations
de façon très lente saccadé et ce qui
fait que c'est un dispositif qui est
assez peu apprécié et utilisé des
personnes donc la prothèse qu'on
développe
dans l'équipe agathe de l'isie re elle
exploite un modèle un peu particulier on
utilise des capteurs de mouvements des
centrales inertielles qui sont disposés
sur le corps de l'utilisateur sur la
prothèse son nombre résiduel est en
permanence le système embarqué de la
prothèse va regarder ces données-là de
mouvement et va essayer de repérer des
compensations les compensations ça va
être des gestuelles inconsciente que
votre corps va exhiber quand par exemple
ils n'arrivent pas à faire quelque chose
quand la prothèse a mal fonctionné un
peu comme quand vous êtes en train de
jouer à un jeu vidéo et que votre
véhicule par exemple ne tourne pas assez
avec la manette vous allez naturellement
et s'est penché en sa direction
eh bien on va capter ça comme autant
d'informations posèrent la prothèse est
bleu à faire la tâche dans cette
direction là et on va ensuite envoyé des
vitesses des instructions aux moteurs de
la prothèse pour la faire se mouvoir
d'une façon coordonnée avec le reste du
corps de la personne
alors la meilleure prothèse c'est pas
forcément le meilleur matériel ou la
proche de contrôler la plus sophistiquée
et donc une des clés dans notre travail
c'est autant de travailler sur la
robotique que sur l'humain être à
l'écouté des besoins comprendre le
contrôle moteur chez les personnes
qu'elles sont en situation d'handicap ou
non et puis d'essayer d'adapter sa au
mieux à leurs attentes
aujourd'hui le défi de marie sera de
battre notre athlète à une des épreuves
du sibat long pour voir remporter la
capsule justement voilà christophe notre
pilote pour le seabel une clarté ça
comment ça va votre écoute super prête
apprête à jouer avec toi est-ce que
avant tout ça tu peux m'expliquer ce que
tu partes
alors je porte une prothèse qui
s'appelle sam dakar qui a de multiples
fonctions et notamment celle de me
permettre de plier le coude de déplier
le coût ni
qui peut me permettre de tourner le
premier à droite ou à gauche et qui peut
également permettre d'ouvrir un crayon
ou peu formés les doigts il ya plusieurs
positions de départ de la main selon les
tâches que j'ai accompli et si je peux
faire tout ça c'est grâce à la
contraction de muscles qu'on a identifié
et d'électrodes qui commandent des
petits moteurs pour accomplir toutes ces
actions
et puis il ya un autre mode qui est
intéressant qui me permet de tourner le
poignet sur une simple situation du haut
du corps en fait un essai assez intuitif
et d'ailleurs c'est de ce mode là donc
je vais me servir pour l'épreuve qui
nous attend ok donc un vrai pilote
accompli était prêt à entamer les profs
qui t'attend on fait une bonne équipe
allez j'ai hâte de voir ça alors
christophe theule est équipé de du
cerceau pour faire le point de faire et
moi je vais vous chronométrés parce que
marie à un enjeu et je doit désigner un
gagnant
wahou c'est impressionnant qui est
entreprise terme arrive à gagner cette
épreuve j'ai fait le bon pari
je pense que christophe est quand même
plus entraînés jeu
alors go waouh
donc là comme tout à l'heure en fait
christophe il se sert du balancier mêmes
mots que tu va utiliser où il suffit de
deux d'orienter correctement et la
prothèse prévoit ce que tu vas faire
mais c'est d'une précision extrême
finalement assez oui
le but n'est pas touché sinon c'est pour
l'instant christophe s'en sort super
bien maintenant c'est très
impressionnant blais petit virage du
rhin de vitres à l'est mais quelle
précision
donc là christophe arrive presque à la
fin ce qui va y arriver
la tension est à son maximum dernier
virage
oh la la c'est magnifique 50 secondes
je crois que c'est mon tour ouais on va
te qui paie est-ce que je vais battre
alors hommes jeudi cependant comme tout
à l'heure allez faites vos paris sur
internet on panique et voilà ces
partitions des classes et tu partiras
quand je te dirai beau hockey un mémoire
de 1 go
concentration précision ce temps ça va
pas trop mal votre modification
j'essaye de faire des petites pointes de
vitesse mais c'est je vais pas me servir
ça s'est fait très peur ce virage alors
c'est vraiment dans la balance du corps
et la concentration quand même aller
elle va nous faire au moins match sont à
l'abri à l'est de la rotation
la france est avec toi de presse
attention à ce que je veux on y est
presque
ça serait bête de toucher au dernier
moment une seconde et christophe avait
fait combien 50 secondes
je suis désolé marie donc les j'ai perdu
ma capsule oui alors je suis trop déçu
bon bah du coup j'ai pas la capsule
c'est pas grave ça arrive
il ya plein de défis qui m'attendent à
toulouse donc je vous propose qu'on se
retrouve là-bas et j'espère que j'aurai
plus de capsules sur place on va essayer
de petite marie marie comment ça va y
aller y est dommage c'est pas grave
c'est sûr que je vais pouvoir en gagner
d'autres
bah oui c'est sûr on est là pour sa part
oui bah oui il est près de 30 secondes
de différence est prise il était trop
fort ouais comme quoi ça mérite pas mal
d'entraînements bah ouais et alors
qu'est ce que ça fait d'avoir une
prothèse bas c'était quand même fou
parce que finalement je n'avais pas
l'impression d'avoir une prothèse et
c'était assez naturelle à paris attend
qu'il ya derrière toi tu me saoules
alors je suis devant un bâtiment qui
s'appelle the dream v6gt déplacés oui on
est parti ce sens là les aliments frais
d'essence atteigne la crs a dream c'est
ça tout à fait faux et c'est ici que tu
va poursuivre talca et à la montée
soudaine et la robotique tout à fait à
la grave tu es merveilleuse limite tu me
fais des bêtises complètement incroyable
aller vite il ya gardé une nouvelle
enveloppe un nouveau défi ce que vous
êtes prêts à y est toutefois qu'il fait
dit
alors qu'est ce qui est écrit tout lire
à deux oreilles c'est avec elle seule
que tu trouveras la capsule
oui il faut qu'ils trouvent il faut que
je trouve tout y est
bonjour oui oui tout minerve
c'est le robot qui derrière nous à en
jouir donc nous allons parler de
localisation binobin active
qu'est ce qu'on appelle la perception
binaural c'est la perception sur la base
de deux oreilles d'accord c'est ce que
j'entends là tout est fait par exemple
voilà et le caractère actif 20
l'expliqué en fait la combinaison de la
perception et du mouvement et pour
commencer je te propose de faire une
toute petite expérience il nous propose
de venir sur cette chaîne
je m'assois voilà est un songe va
émerger de l'oeuvre de ses haut parleurs
je te propose de me dire d'où ils
viennent et puis on va en discuter un
petit peu je ferme les yeux si tu veux
mais n'ont pas même si tu veux aller je
ferme les yeux
à gauche c'est bien ça donc ce qui s'est
passé en fait c'est que pour localiser
horizontalement se sont tues à utiliser
implicitement de ce qu'on appelle des
différences intervalles donc ce sont des
différences d'aptitudes et de temps du
son qui parviennent à tes oreilles je le
suis un tout petit peu perturbé parce
qu'en général quand on demande aux gens
comme ça de donner nos régions du sud
ils ont tendance à bouger ce que tu l'as
pas fait bréchet rester très statique
mais c'est très bien qu'un phénomène est
le fait de bouger rend compte en fait
delà de cette combinaison entre autre
perception et mouvement qu'est ce que tu
en train de me dire c'est qu'en fait
quand on écoute c'est pas juste
l'oreille c'est l'espace comment bouger
c'est mécaniquement ses complexes que
juste une oreille c'est ça donc la
perception est un processus à petit
oratoire et donc ceux ci se manifeste
par le fait qu' il ya non seulement
l'analyse des signaux mais également le
fait qu' il ya des feedbacks donc ça
peut être difficile à bhl de niveau
qu'on dit yves wehrli niveau moteur de
niveau cognitif vers des niveaux
perceptuelle il ya également des
feedbacks haut niveau ça sourit moteur
c'est l'intelligence est précisément le
reboot ou hier c'est ce que nous avions
développée nous avions développé des
stratégies de combinaisons de la
perception du monde et du contrôle du
mouvement pour mieux trouver l'origine
des sceaux ce sera la seconde partie
donc pour trouver l'origine dans son il
faut se déplacer
c'est ce qu'ont fait son bonhomme ancien
moment que j'espérais c'est comme quand
tu sors et louis
quand la tribune voilà voilà donc
s'imaginer comme un homme va voir le
film ainsi que l'on ne passera aux
nigérians les nous allons devoir laisser
marie et patrick échanger encore un peu
parce que nous on va découvrir ce robot
en effet en images la démonstration qui
va suivre concerne la localisation
active binaural de sources sonores donc
nous sommes dotés d'audition binaural
sur la base de deux oreilles ce sont des
capteurs qui paraissent relativement
rudimentaire quand on est con paralysie
ou aux yeux pourtant nous avons une
capacité assez exceptionnel à donner du
sens au monde de son euro qui nous
entoure lorsqu'on perçoit un mélange de
sons pour analyser la scène auditive qui
nous entourent ont fait émerger un
ensemble de sources subjective sur la
base de plusieurs critères
quelques fréquences implique de thèmes
répétition mais également l'origine
spatiale des sources et donc la
localisation de source est inhérente à
l'analyse de scène leur bout que vous
voyez intérieurement avait été développé
dans le cadre d'un projet européenne de
psycho acoustique l'objectif était de
caractériser la perception humaine dans
sa dimension active exploratoire nous
lasse nous nous intéressions sur des
boucles de rétroaction qui combinait
perception du mouvement ou plus bas
niveau en vue de localiser de manière
binaural horizontale des sources son nom
c'est un petit peu ce que fait mon chat
en action de chasse afin de le
déterminer l'origine de sa proie
il bouge inconsciemment mais ils bougent
également ce soir il est beaucoup plus
pertinent d'essayer de placer la source
dans la forêt auditive c'est dans cette
zone nous sommes plus sensibles à
l'origine spatiale et tant qu'à faire à
essayer de se rapprocher de la source
marie votre
défi consistera à vous substituer aux
robots vous réaliserez ce feedback
sensori moteur entre perception du
mouvement andante recevant ce que
perçoit le robot et en le commandant
logistique en vue de réaliser la
localisation active binaural tout
fonctionne un peu comme les oreilles
d'un chat qui s'orientent
automatiquement une source
alors autant il n'y a pas très quillan
me donner un casque à quoi ça va me
servir tout ça donc ce casque peut te
permettre de sentir le saut spatialisé
binaural que perçoit le robot a donc
j'aurais pensé tu prends un petit peu
dans ses oreilles et ce juriste il va te
permettre de le piloter
donc le il faudra que quand tu le pilote
tué magie tu imagines que tu es dans sa
position spatiale n'est ce pas hu a donc
peut-être combien sont pas d'accord
allez c'est parti
dis moi si je suis apte à droite tu
risque de trouver un certain moment dans
certaines configurations entre toi et la
source tu risques d'avoir des ambiguïtés
c'est normal et en général c'est le
mouvement qui permet de lever cette
ambiguïté parce que je vais te proposait
donc pour piloter le joystick tu as ici
la vitesse ici tu avance recule pas pu
voter comme ceci et moi je vais ici
lancer une source trompette mais on
entretient une autre source parasites
histoire de compliquer un petit peu mais
tu verras qu'assez rapidement c'est
comme si elle n'était pas là et le défi
sera donc que tu trouves de cale
haut-parleurs bien cette source
s'il bon alors c'est ça quel défi j'ai
hâte je vais lancer je vais contrôler
tout rires et alors je ne sais pas si
vous avez complété j'entends ce
qu'entend le robot c'est complètement
faux
j'attends ton top départ viennent de
supporter ce jour est comme ça lâche et
donc là j'entends la trempette à gauche
marie doit se diriger alors là je
l'entends bien face à moi je crois non
j'avais l'impression que c'est faire en
phase mais c'est à droite
[Musique]
donc là je l'entends très beau c'est la
brume ensemble
[Musique]
mais qui définitivement cette réussite
mutuelle
c'est la bonne réponse c'est ça le gêne
y est c'était incroyable comme
expérience sur nos trente secondes je te
proposera peut-être décidé de reculer un
petit peu le robot et décide de
localiser d'autres sources
allez y en a deux oui c'est la voix j'ai
l'habitude de jouer aux jeux vidéo mais
ça franchement ça vaut le détour
[Musique]
localisé l'otage
j'entends ce fait ça pour vraiment se
mettre à côté du lit pour comprendre ce
qui a changé bien par ici pour ne pas
perturber le championnat et je vous
propose aussi à les ondes de garder
aussi beer les oreilles grandes ouvertes
parce qu'à la fin des missions vous
pourrez pas s'il est au quiz il peut
être ça
est-ce que c'était plus facile plus
difficile c'est plus difficile peut-être
plus difficile
oui j'ai eu l'impression que ça venait
de là bas un moment pour conclure le
rebond est capable pas faudra combiner
zone de la perception du mouvement non
seulement 17 de déterminer l'azimut mais
aussi de déterminer la distance le soir
oui c'est ça parce qu en fait oui c'est
vraiment comment l'orientation du corps
entre lignes du robot va réussir à
localiser se sont complètement
alors est ce qu'on peut et qu'on est ce
qu'on pourrait faire un nouveau sens par
les robots vont tourner dans l'autre il
ya un nombre croissant d'équipements
robotique qui effectue mal travaillent
sur ces aspects auditionne en robotique
donc si nous discipliner
cette percée cette modalité perceptuelle
est utilisé depuis moins longtemps que
la vision ou la grainerie laser externe
mais ça va de manière presque deux mois
cela compense toujours on se dit bon
pour me repérer localiser je pense à mes
yeux mais quand on ferme les yeux et les
oreilles nous servent énormément europe
et regarder un espace où c'est dingue
c'est comme ça confie juste le dernier
monstre de ce projet c'était au projet
la boîte de psycho acoustique face à
l'abc caustique comme fait c'était déjà
que travailler sur des formulations de
théorique des problématiques de de
perception auditive est précisément
c'était l'objectif était de fabriquer un
modèle exhaustif de la perception de
villeroy d'une haine qui rendent compte
du caractère ou actifs exploratoire et
le second rôle a été le support
expérimental du projet c'était super
merci je te rend ça je reviendrai
peut-être jouer un jour avec emma
capsule on allait oublier
on va quand même pas partir son cap sur
avec ceci avec les trompettes
franchement fan fait pour la victoire
versez pas pris et alors le farcir le
staff a toutefois pas parce que nous
avons un petit message vidéo pour soi en
bombe sur l'écran ici lui en effet ce à
dire que le laboratoire aurait ainsi
compiègne un génial des robots sur mon
salaire de robots à première vue bonjour
ma vie je voulais te présenter les
véhicules autonomes de notre laboratoire
les recherches qu'on développe sur ses
véhicules autonomes sont la perception
multi-capteurs la localisation fiable et
intègre le contrôle et la commande de
ces véhicules est aussi la communication
entre les véhicules ce qu'on appelle la
communication véhicule à véhicule au
véhicule infrastructure donc toutes ces
recherches sont basées sur des
techniques telles que l'intelligence
artificielle le traitement des données
l'automatique d'une manière générale
donc ce qu'on va chercher à faire dans
ces véhicules
c'est d'intégrer des logiciels qui sont
capables de récupérer d'acquérir des
données à partir de capteurs ou de
sources d'information qui sont installés
dans ces véhicules ou qui sont externes
et de combiner toutes ces informations
pour avoir une représentation de la
situation fiable pour être capable
ensuite de planifier une trajectoire ou
de décider de la route qu'on va à suivre
pour que les véhicules puissent apporter
une aide au conducteur ou être autonome
sur certaines tâches de conduite
ce véhicule est capable d'avancer tout
seul et de le diriger aussi on peut ne
pas tenir le volant ne pas appuyer sur
l'accélérateur et il ya aussi des
capteurs des caméras intelligentes qui
sont capables de détecter les panneaux
de détecter les lignes blanches de
détecter les piétons ou les autres
véhicules bien sûr il y a aussi des
capteurs lidar qui retourne ce qu'on
appelle un nuage de points qui vont nous
permettre aussi d'avoir une
représentation très dense de
l'environnement et aussi en à des
capteurs qui nous renseigne sur l'état
de la voiture sur sa vitesse
sur le nombre de tours qu'on fait des
roues et bien sûr il ya de nombreux
ordinateurs embarqués pour faire tous
les calculs dont on a besoin pour
conduire ces véhicules autonomes donc
les véhicules autonomes du laboratoire
diaz iq sont des zoos et qui sont
robotisés c'est à dire qu'elles ont des
capacités et de perception de
localisation mais aussi d'action c'est à
dire qu'elles peuvent conduire tout seul
tous ces travaux se font en
collaboration avec d'autres laboratoires
ou avec des industriels et en
particulier au travers d'un laboratoire
commun qui s'appelle steve hallam qu'un
laboratoire entre renault et le
laboratoire diaz hic sur la thématique
des systèmes impec tu de localisation et
de perception pour les véhicules
autonomes ou el amari j'espère que tu
vas voir plein de robots fabuleuse et
j'espère surtout tu pourras venir nous
rendre visite à compiègne dans notre
laboratoire pour voir nos véhicules ou à
l'est mais attends tu te rends compte ça
veut dire que en fait il ya des voitures
qui peuvent presque en tout cas on est
en train d'élaborer des voitures qui
peuvent s'auto piloter tout seul mais
oui pour ceux qui n'ont pas leur servir
bien jouer tu es vraiment une petite
rigolote un livre et marie elle risque
était prêt pour la suite dit oui alors à
temps parce que la chance qu'on me dire
on a vu des robots qui peuvent bouger
qui gère des mouvements complètement fou
on a vu un robot qui peut être sensible
à l'art un robot qui peut entendre et
spatialisé le sou jeu j'ai vraiment hâte
de voir la suite la wii là tu envisages
actuellement que j'ai pu lire sur
l'écran derrière toi de guy les bisons
rares acteurs de savoir ce qu'il ya dans
ces calculs vont aussi et oui parce que
par leur c'est la suite regard oui tu
étais petit garçon
la wac je suis attendu une nouvelle fois
je vois un petit bonhomme qui m'attend
j'y vais j'y vais trop bien
bonjour bonjour peppers alors hop et le
rap et être indiquer où se trouve alors
à peine deux mois semblait mais vous
allez me faire grimper
oui
ça te fait partie d'un projet européen
qui se passait en finlande elle a été
développée aussi avec des partenaires
regard d'autres pays doit donc je dois
monter des escaliers il n'ya pas
d'escalier messi est ce que t'as pas
bien sûr que je suis je suis capable de
monter des escaliers
green team ou soutien-gorge et
apparemment j'ai juste à suivre le guide
il est en train de me guider
alors je le suis il est beaucoup trop
mignon se fait peur c'est tard je te
fais confiance 1
qu'est ce qu'ils regardent aller je me
mets en face de toi peppers donc là il
est en train de me dire que la capsule
n'est pas visible d'ici mais calais
waouh
donc là c'est vraiment fort boyard je
vais devoir monter djezzy mais oui c'est
très compliqué
si t'as pas compris tu peux venu si
c'est bon j'ai compris il m'a dit
d'aller par là bas et de monter des
escaliers et qu'il était très content et
que j'allais lui toujours même le chemin
si on prend les escaliers à ta gauche
tourne à gauche ensuite tourner à droite
et la capsule sera sur ta gauche quand
tu marches donc là j'y vais merci tu
aurais pu venir avec moi quand même peur
mais bon je vais y aller tout seul j'ai
compris la retrouvera tout à l'heure
d'été terrain bat salies oui vous faites
monter des escaliers carrément c'est
l'épreuve la plus physique du live je
suis sûr mais j'arrivais à inventer tous
et d'escaliers cap les jours qu'est ce
que ce coup oui alors gauche et l'eau
est ce que tu veux pas trouvé une
enveloppe mais non mais qu'est ce que
c'est
une capsule déjà mais il n'y a pas d'
enveloppe de 7 les princes c'était
vraiment un cadeau il me dit donc s'en
passe peppers franchement je l'admet on
se fait peur mais je te propose d'aller
leur pc ainsi que ses concepteurs et
nous on va le découvrir en donc on vient
de voir marie et pepper peppers qui est
un robot de service autonome qui est là
pour aider les gens et en l'occurrence
pour les guider et les aider à trouver
leur chemin
physiquement il ressemble aux autres
robots peppers qu'on peut voir un peu
partout dans le monde dans les commerces
mais en l'occurrence les logiciels qui
font tourner celui là ont été construits
ici aulas et sont uniquement présente
dans ce robot est donc les
fonctionnalités
et de guidage sont uniquement dans ce
robot pour guider il pointe il parle il
peut éventuellement se déplacer de
quelques mètres
comme on a pu le voir avec marie de la
même manière qu'une personne qui demande
son chemin une autre dans la rue la
personne à qui il demande ne se déplace
pas jusqu'à sa destination finale
il fait seulement quelques mètres pour
lui montrer l'intersection la plus
proche par exemple
la particularité de notre robot peppers
et qu'il sait se positionner par rapport
à son interlocuteur pour lui indiquer le
chemin en fait peppers essaye de se
positionner de manière à rendre
l'interaction la plus naturelle possible
ici là essayer de former une formation
en triangle entre lui la porte et mari
de cette manière marie pouvez regarder à
la fois peppers et la porte sans avoir à
tourner trop la tête
pepper connaît la liste de tous les
éléments de son environnement et comment
ils sont reliés les uns par rapport aux
autres
par exemple il sait que l'escalier se
trouve dans le hall du bâtiment à partir
de tous ces éléments il est capable de
générer un chemin à partir d'un point de
départ jusqu'à un point d'arrivée
il faut savoir que pepper n'a pas la
phrase explicative du chemin pré
enregistrés dans son système
il va là générées dynamiquement en
fonction du chemin qu'il a calculé
précédemment
sa particularité c'est qui va être
capable de se projeter le long du chemin
pour savoir si l'humain va devoir
tourner soit à droite soit à gauche
vis-à-vis de sa position future le long
du chemin
le robot sait qu'il doit agir
on utilise le terme c'est pour le robot
mais c'est pas vraiment savoir
il a un logiciel dédié à chacune ses
fonctionnalités
la génération de chemin la navigation la
verbalisation au dessus de tout ça en un
logiciel coordinateur qui va chapeauter
tous ces logiciels pour les faire
fonctionner au bond
marie tu es donc retrouvés à bondy et
guillaume et avec la capsule
j'ai eu quand même un acolyte de choix
qui m'a extrêmement bien guidé c'était
très précis et du coup j'ai vu vachement
d'un magazine mais alors c'est vous qui
vous occupez pts et nous pas que nous en
fait c'est quasiment 7 doctorants de
permanents à ingénieur et d'autres
équipes de recherche partout dans le
monde en fait c'est un beau projet
européen donc savons beaucoup de monde
pour juste faire fonctionner ça on a
l'impression que c'est simple mes nerfs
sénat quand même et puis un peu ce mois
ci une frappe avec parce qu'on a
maintenant que il
elle est super sympathique il ya un air
très j'ai presque son type de l'empathie
est vraiment ce robot avait envie de
m'aider dans ma quête c'était assez
hallucinant alors qu'avant j'ai vu des
robots qui était impressionnant mais pas
autant en pratique comment ça se fait
son apparence a été conçu pour ça pour
que se révélèrent gentil qui soit
acceptable par les gens que les gens
aient envie de lui parler parce que
c'est un robot de service qui est fait
pour être dans les supermarchés dans les
centres commerciaux dans les familles
éventuellement dans son but c'est
vraiment de guider bas celui là en
particulier et c'est un les capacités
qui là ils sont que dans cette version
là où dans les autres du projet mais un
autre peur que tu vas pouvoir croiser
dans un autre contexte il aura pas ce
même programme sur lui parce que là
c'est un projet de recherche donc on en
veut
donne-nous
notre code notre programme informatique
qu'on attend sua se trouve là mais les
autres ils on passe à chacun sa
fonctionnalité chaque parent est unique
c'est trop bien mais alors qu'est ce qui
peut faire j'ai vu que alors le
mouvement de bras était hyper fluide ni
bouger les doigts on ferme où les
membres et doit en même temps donc il va
pas fort wayne c'est comme mon très cher
lorsqu'on a l'impression finale sur
cette manche à la serbie à travailler
parce que ça me gêne pas le ménage pas
il va pointer être capable de se
déplacer par rapport à ta position en
fait c'est pour ça qu'ils s'étaient
vraiment décalé et a pris va être
capable de coups de t'expliquer le
chemin il va calculer dynamiquement il
va calculer phrase dynamiquement donc
rien et préprogrammés là dessus oui je
t'entends mari j'avais l'air de
t'approcher l'étape avec les journées le
genre est demandé avez peur d'être
indiquer où aller
ok alors à une what is your next up et
peur celle me what is my next up clean
de jon arryn a donc une histoire de
drones allez je te suivent en fait j'ai
plus rien à faire moi je suis le guide
vachement bien l'anglais marie frenkiel
même y jouit d'un très bon je comprends
rien
on va en fait il est en train de me dire
que c'est dans cette direction et qu'il
est en train de m'expliquer lamentations
il me dit d'aller tout droit de
traverser le corridor et ensuite d'aller
à gauche yes avec guide allez vas-y
aride qui ont peur merci beaucoup c'est
parti pour la suite de l'aventuré je
trouve alors street
droit devant oh là là lily j'ai vraiment
trop trop hâte
et oui tout le monde se débat public et
josé vie c'est quoi la surprise c'est le
monde qui est tombée des capsules
ah ben je vais ranger ma capsule tient
monsieur sorbet c'est impressionnant
merci monsieur sorbets bonjour je crois
que je suis dans la john eriane on me
parlait vendredi une enveloppe à une
enveloppe c'est pour moi mais c'est
beaucoup
j'aimerais tu la vois où cet endroit est
trop pont alors on va découvrir l'énigme
ensemble l'union fait la force des
robots volants
encore faut-il qu'ils se voient ça c'est
chung anime alors bonjour moi je suis
marie enchanté voilà quel est cet
endroit on parle de robot volant mais
juste avant au mahdi drôme c'est quoi
les différences c'est une question de
vocabulaire
non non non donc on pourrait faire
baisser un peu les robots c'est
finalement c'est vers hombo cdc des
machines avec une certaine autonomie et
de capacité les calculs des capacités de
perception les capacités de décision et
surtout de crise et de l'interaction
laïcité dans l'espace où on fabrique en
zone euro à rien c'est un atelier
c'est un atelier donc c'est c'est toi
qui fabriquent tous les pouvoirs à ses
collègues donc la robotique est
multidisciplinaire dans notre équipe il
ya des personnages des conférences très
varié il ya des sanguinaires mécanique
qui vont s'intéresser aux les structures
des robots après on avait l'habitude de
la partie électronique logiciel
dans l'équipe on travaille
principalement c'est vrai la partie
logicielle mais on fabrique aussi tout
ce qu'il faut au tour pour pouvoir
rester vraiment et si c'est de la route
et de sa licence expérimentale
ok mais alors question moi j'ai vu
depuis le début de l' aventure des
robots sur terre ça sert à quoi de faire
des robots qui veulent ça sert entre
autres à leh dans des endroits où les
robots qui roulait qui marche mais ils
permettent de faire des tâches qui sont
complémentaires à celles des robots
terrestres
donc c'est pas juste des drones qui
simplement vol que l'on peut connaître
les drones de loisirs non là ce sont des
bruits qu'ils sont capables de faire des
factions ont travaillé sur la
manipulation à rennes dont le travail
des systèmes robotiques aérien qui
manipulent et donc ces tutus peuvent en
a ici qui les regarde bien gros gros qui
a qui rendra donc il va pouvoir voler
manipuler les objets
et on pas on va pouvoir les voir un
robot qui sont en train de développer
tester en ce moment il s'appelle frais
je sais c'est une bruine volante hockey
au niveau du drone qui exécutent des
tâches c'est plus juste un robot qui va
le pavois la c1
donc en fait c'est ces systèmes c'est un
système multi room
donc s'il ya trop robots qui sont
ensemble on y colle une plate forme et
cette plate avant il va pouvoir les
prendre des objets manipulés ces objets
de pouvoir contrôler la position dans
l'espace de ces objets donc là c'est pas
un drone c3 donc là c'est plusieurs on
peut dire ses trois robots est ok mais
après c'est un système robotique nous
les robots système robotique donc en
fait ça dépend du point de vue ses trois
robots mais en fait c'est un tout un
système a tancé ces robots et l'union
fait la force de nombreuses absences
donc là on allait faire des tests donc
tu vas aller voir voler tu vas pouvoir
même les faire voler toi moi je vais les
faire voler alors ça donc en fait si tu
peux te rends compte que c'est un
système assez complet
longue vie à trois robots imaginons pour
faire voler tant que redescendre des
trois pilotes mais oui 17 ordonne donc
il ya une seule personne mais en fait
manipuler donc de faire voler leur
plateforme inter c'est simple droit
c'est toute la famille qui vient
derrière donc il ya des sags ont donc
son appel de planification de mouvements
à des commandes
sylvain que avec les esters on et
spécifie la position et l'orientation de
la patate chaude que cet agrume font le
reste hamadi nous bombarder bien parce
que c'est un peu ce qui est des autres
équipes
voilà donc ça peut être un problème de
batterie mais alors est-ce que tu peux
m'expliquer ses filets oui c'est quoi
c'est une espèce de zone de sécurité
est ce que si un vin qui s'en va donc
peut-être me remplacer et ben en
attendant moi je vais poser quelques
questions à nelly melli tu m'entends oui
marie est ce que que disent les
internautes de tout ça parce que alors
moi je suis complètement halluciné ce
que je viens de voir quand même c'est
dont ses trois robots volants qui aussi
qu'ils ont décollé ensemble déjà lors
des petits drones tout seul j'en ai déjà
vu mais alors 3 comme ça c'est vraiment
fabuleux mais justement on va regarder
une petite vidéo proviendrait vont
comprendre plus en profondeur ces
petites machines fait partie on vient de
voir un système multi robot qu'on
appelle les flics rennes c'est un
système capable de manipuler les objets
dans des rencontres langue leur position
et l'orientation nos robots sont
capables d'échanger des forces avec
l'environnement et donc dé manipuler les
objets ça de manière autonome ou semi
autonome donc on a conçu ce système avec
trois robots
rattaché à une plateforme en farsi
camille et spécifiquement pour pouvoir
effectuer cette île des tâches par sa
conception le système incapable
d'assister à certaines perturbations
comme je le vend par exemple ce qui
serait pas possible si l'on transporté
l'objet avec un solde roanne où un
hélicoptère et un seul câble on peut
envisager des applications comparaissant
de la construction dans des lieux
inaccessibles ou dangereux aussi des
missions de secours de sauvetage
le système complexe pour pouvoir être
piloté par une seule personne
nous avons développé des algorithmes ans
qu'on dit avoir une planification de
mouvements qui vont calculer la
trajectoire des robots pour satisfaire
d'une part les consignes spécifié par
par l'opérateur mais aussi les
contraintes propres systèmes
ces contraintes peuvent être dans le
géométrique par exemple le robot il peut
pas rentrer en collision avec les
obstacles au tournis avec lui mais aussi
d'ordre dynamique pour satisfaire des
contraintes liées aux forces dans les
câbles et aussi à la saturation des
moteurs cette planification des mangues
peut être local pour calculer localement
les trajectoires
suite aux consignes en ni par
l'opérateur mais peut être aussi globale
donc on peut imaginer que le robot
fonctionne de manière complètement
autonome et calculs entièrement sa
trajectoire pour aller d'un point à un
bonnet mari le défi qui va falloir
relever de savoir quel est le système
qui a utilisé par le robot pour se
localiser
oui devant tout de suite où des vies
alors quel est mon défi donc ton défi
c'est de savoir comment le système
c'est localisé comment les robots
comment on sait quelle est la position
des robots complique donc c'est le cas
pour vous servez là en intérieur quand
ils sont en espérer une autre liste des
autres systèmes
donc on aura donc là je dois me
focaliser sur ce qu'ils sont juste à
l'intérieur je pense que tu as vu
d'autres sites d'autres robots il ya des
robots qui utilise la caméra des prix
d'or mais le système qui utilise ce rôle
là pour ces localités que je pense que
tu as vu aussi tout à fait reprendre et
peut-être que regarder dans les airs
pour être aidée du seul ennui à est ce
que ce sont des capteurs parce que c'est
de ce décor mêlant caméras infrarouges
donc s'il ya des caméras infrarouges est
ce que tu peux me dire ce que c'est que
c'est ça m'intrigue les petites boules
cd des bulls qui sont utilisés pour qui
ce en vue pour se met donc les petits
boules vont avec les caméras infrarouges
alors comment ça fonctionne c'est avec
la lumière
moi si c'est ça c'est un système en fait
il a trouvé la réponse à celle scellée
la caméra qui localise ces petites
billes c'est le système de capture de
mouvements qui comprennent utilise dans
mais seulement quatre manches encore
fêtards ne trompent pas - champions
les dépannages
si tout va bien je suis vraiment
c'est pas grave si sensible que
présentait trop logiciels et d'art je
suis contente d'avoir vu ces deux fois
le décollage vous rendez compte vendre
et chance alors mon défi de me donner
aux capsules
donc en fait ces robots normalement il
peut manipuler les objets donc il peut
soulever des objets donc il sait que
j'écoute vraiment que j'aurais dû
soulever une boîte l'a donc tu peux
aller soulever la voiture bleue moi je
vais aller soulever la boîte mais je
risquerais pas que j'y vais c'est les
alliés américains non mais regardez moi
ces machines turbo bon bah je vais
soulever la la il est en face de toi
ce sont les moelleux écoute très bien
mais après tu crois que les intérêts de
nos sites et nancy les droits de nourrir
oh oui on attendait l'issue de prouver
la casse on revient est-ce que les
drones nous mais ça a l'air d'aller
quand même et marierait cela reste là je
ne vais pas changer parce qu'ils me les
droits des sans paraben
oui tu vas récupérer toutes ses classes
il a déjà et on passe trop vite
et oui alors à présent tu veux les
ouvrir pour nous à tout tu as sur sa
droite
ça fait un petit plateau donc je vais
pour t'aider vas-y je sors tout un cap
sur les faits je sais le milliard ça
prouve que ça marche pas toujours
et c'est bien mais oui mon diluer les
recherches tout à fait alors c'est parti
compte jean neige est tombée alors j'en
ai perdu une banque une deux
3 4 5
c'est tout à leur certain paul penser
qu'il y avait peut-être un qr code
n'hésitez pas à donner vos idées de ce
qui pourrait y avoir à l'intérieur
personnellement je n'ai aucune idée de
ce qui les intérieurs à nouveau ensemble
qu'est ce que c'est une image est ce que
je vais réussir à sortir je n'ai aucune
idée de ce que c'est mais en j'imagine
avoir se ressemblant pas un petit puzzle
tout ça on va découvrir je la pose là tu
attends deuxième image
oui c'est un puzzle géant
[Musique]
et de trois alors y est je peux
commencer peut-être à ce à l'heure de se
compléter
tac tac tac bon je vais continuer à les
ouvrir mais je suis trop impatient je
veux jouer ensuite
je vais tout les sortir et puis après je
composerai tech
il m'en reste encore 1 mais du coup ils
m'ont il me manque une pièce je vais
réussir quand même on croise les doigts
en tout cas tu es le plein visage des
internautes
rarement un jeu gens veulent en jean
blanc mais tenez vraiment beaucoup
qui dit une image de revoir si tu es
peut-être à face à la fin peut-être une
image de robots avons constitué alors je
vous avais je veux faire quand même dans
mon sens allez marie à l'image un peu
violent photons un peu dommage parce que
je pense que c'est simple merci à riols
mais qu'est ce que c'est je suis perdue
a alors on dirait une pièce vous dit
avec des petits fauteuils
alors ça va parce que ça te fait penser
à quelque chose ça me fait penser à
quelque chose
curé pas vu l'ombre d'un panda marché
peut-être une petite pièce qui pourrait
y ressembler c'est vrai que tout à
l'heure sur tellement je suis passé
devant une pièce classée et les symboles
rouge un point d'interrogation massa y
est je crois qu'on est bon là alors tu
as devant toi j'ai une pièce vidéo un
espèce de plans 3d d'une pièce et je
pense que il faut que j'aille dans cette
pièce
et qu'est ce qui s'est dit sur ta droite
ça oui
eh ben c'est une très bonne question on
dirait un petit robot
oui et bien jusqu'où il va falloir que
tu veux c'est bien cette petite image
ah oui bon est ce que tu te souviens de
temps à partie devant je me souviens
d'un appartement je les croisais tout à
l'heure on va y aller allez c'est parti
mactac magolon de l'autre côté revient
sur tes pas mal ressenti a mal parlé oui
allez tu chantes tu chose oui mais si
vous auriez pu m'envoyer peppers kong
idée c'était quand même plus à part tout
droit à lille oui mais il ya une entrée
oui on dirait un appartement je rentre
ou lit et qu'il te voir chercher quelque
chose à ton avis c'est quoi qu'est-ce
que je dois rechercher une enveloppe
avalant les mines enveloppe non c'est
vas-y mon blog c'est donc en jouer est
ce que ton petit puzzle de t d un petit
peu mais bon qu'est ce que tu es ab sur
ton puzzle arrive
j'avais une flèche oui et quoi d'autre
un petit robot et oui je dois chercher
ce petit roi voilà là mais il fait
quelle taille des jeux pleins de
questions alors il est pas là il est
peut-être par là
allez mari oui eh ben moi je me sens pas
ou ne vous inquiétez pas reviendrez pas
à gauche pichot de chauffe de chauffe
calquer ce robot est ce que tu comme
donnant en lice
[Musique]
je dois être une bibliothèque
je vois une bibliothèque je suis fan
bibliothèque qu'est maintenant tu chaud
il est trop petit je pensais que c'était
un robot géant mois aurait gardé les
buts 3e et un petit cadeau qu elle est
trop mignonne ça fait entre aux beaux
souvenirs ici c'est trop bien les
machines roots et de la part de moi
avons versé mais ça sent pas et leurs
maris je crois que quelqu'un tomber
quelqu'un m'attend bonjour bonjour marie
alors cette aventure bah c'était
complètement fou j'ai découvert vraiment
des trucs j'ai jugé plus les mots alors
justement on va mettre les mots d'abord
je m'appelle raja enchantait l'aja je
suis marie bien alors tu as vu beaucoup
de robots il ya eu beaucoup de choses là
ton esprit doit en ébullition on va
mettre un peu d'ordre
allez je vais te proposer un jeu encore
oui un dernier joué combien je suis tout
seul là voilà on est en forme
alors tu vois toutes ces images toutes
ces photos tous les remous que tu as vu
et puis on a préparé quelques phrases et
tu vois tu vas pouvoir associer les
phrases avec les robots je vais te les
lire les phrases et toi tu choisis le
robot qui va bien je découvre pas là
commençons par là la première phrase la
parole et le langage le mouvement le
geste le regard contribuent tous à
l'interaction entre les humains entre
les robots et les humains aussi ça
t'évoque sa femme évoque franchement ce
n'est pas ça mais je dirais nina 5 c'est
pas du tout ça mais ça m'évoque
parce que c'était vraiment mais de toute
façon le mot regard tout de suite on
pense à nina avec ses grands yeux alors
la photo de mina tu la mets un côté de
la phrase je vois que notre interaction
est complexe
oui exige énormément de sens énormément
d'action de regard de mouvement et c'est
ça justement qu'on essaye de comprendre
et de mettre en oeuvre sur les robes ou
oui alors deuxième phrase la marche
bipèdes et le contrôle du corps entier
exigent des calculs complexes que notre
cerveau faire en permanence et sur notre
cerveau il a une représentation du corps
en est cependant nous très complexe par
rapport aux robots et on essaye de
mettre ça en oeuvre sur les remous on
est encore loin des performances
humaines mais on avance petit à petit
cette époque qui à quoi ça aurait pu
évoquer peppers dans cet aspect un peu
de représentations du corps mais il ya
le mot bipèdes et je n'ai vu je crois
qu'un robot bipède c'est pyrène pyrène
j'attends c'est rennes qui a eu deux
jambes en tant que ça et voilà ok donc
bipèdes et voilà vient alors la
robotique
ça regarde vraiment beaucoup de choses
ça peut être utilisé pour beaucoup de
choses ça peut être utilisé pour réparer
des êtres humains et les rétablir leur
donner des fonctions quelques que les
êtres humains ont perdu ou des membres
qu'ils ont perdu et avec ses membres on
peut aussi augmenter nos capacités
physiques
alors c'est facile avec christophe
donc je vous dirais les protège les
prothèses lopez alors les prothèses
effectivement ça peut permettre à des
personnes amputées comme tu as vue de
retrouver cette capacité donc c'est
extrêmement utile c'est extrêmement
important mais
on peut aussi donner aux prothèses des
mécanismes qui n'existent pas vraiment
par exemple la prothèse que tu as vu
avait une centrale inertielle qui permet
tait est vrai de se localiser exactement
et puis on peut lui donner une certaine
force qui est plus importante que la
force humaine peut se poser des
questions sur l'augmentation la
frontière entre l'augmentation et la
réparation ou retrouver des capacités et
n'est pas si simple que ça et ça peut
nous donner à penser alors maintenant
les robots on les fabrique c'est les
humains qui les font et on leur donne
des formes qui sont adaptés à leurs
fonctions ont ici c'est un robot par
exemple sous marin on va lui donner la
forme d'un sous-marin parce que ça peut
bien alors ils peuvent intervenir à des
endroits très éloignées et dangereux
pour les humains
par exemple sur le planet sur mars et y
accomplir des tâches diverses
je vais ajouter un peu parfois
le robot n'est pas tout seul à une
équipe de qui est la force raja alors
c'est les procédés drones aller et
figure toi que effectivement il ya un
projet pour envoyer un drone sur mars
c'est vrai mais comment c'est possible
alors que l'atmosphère est très ténue il
suffit de le concevoir de manière
affectivement pouvoir s'envoler dans
cette atmosphère ténue et il pourra
explorer plus loin que les robots qui se
déplace sur le sol on lit endroits
éloignés mais moi je me dis bon
éloigné sur la terre mais pas sur mars
et oui on peut aller sur mars avec des
robots et qui nous remplace en quelque
sorte continuer alors des capteurs un
traitement du signal approprié
permettent aux robots de mieux percevoir
l'environnement par le son par l'image
et de se localiser
c'est un sens de plus pour le robot
parce qu'on pense toujours
la vision c'est vrai et ça t'évoque quoi
à ma femme évoque touriste doing things
justice et voilà tout y est ce parce
qu'il a deux oreilles comme nous amy
donc de repérer le son et sa provenance
et en plus en se déplaçant mieux repérer
d'où il vient un robot peut apprendre
reconnaître des oeuvres d'art
peut-il avoir un sens esthétique qui
c'est notre ami de rincon jeudi notre
avis parce que vraiment j'avais beaucoup
de sympathie pour lui avec son petit
chapeau melon
voilà alors berenson qui était donc à un
historien de l'art quand on a ici
essayer de voir comment finalement nous
les êtres humains apprécions l'art et
c'est comme ça qu'il a appris c'est à
dire qu'il a appris en demandant aux
gens finalement parce que lui en propre
ses machines le bo ne sais pas ce que
c'est donc finalement c'est une
expérience qui nous fait nous même
transmettre à une machine notre
appréciation de l'art puis à des gens
qui aiment qu'ils n'aiment pas donc ils
adaptent et lui au fond il ne ressent
pas de sens esthétique
qui est liée à nos émotions à ce qu'on a
vécu donc ils l'intègrent nos émotions
entre viré mais oui mais sans les
comprendre
c'est ça la différence toujours qu'on va
voir avec les machines c'est qu'ils ont
l'apparence de ce que nous sommes ce que
nous ressentons mais non pas la réalité
c'est vrai qu'on est souvent tenté de se
dire que ils nous comprennent ou qui me
ressemble et parfois la frontière mais
on est prisonnier d'une autre langage on
utilise les mêmes termes la date n'a pas
fini le robot peut être doté d'un sens
de l'orientation on peut se localiser
calculer ses déplacements on peut ainsi
guidé des humains dans le mot guide
c'est mon petit pétard préféré c'est pas
peur j'ai pas de doute là dessus
alors c'est un peu fini parce que c'est
plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît quand en
fait vous donner à quelqu'un son chemin
ou expliquer son chemin en fait vous
vous mettez à sa place comment dire
enlever vous mettez dans ses chaussures
vous mettez à sa place hier que vous
pensez comme lui ou les dites vous
partez la bravoure ils vous tournez à
gauche et c'est la gauche de la personne
positionné à l'autre en place ont donc
finalement cet appel la théorie de
l'esprit serre se mettre à la place de
quelqu'un d'autre c'est quelque chose
qui est propre à notre capacité de
raisonner de raisonner sur l'autre avec
l'autre connaissances et capacités et ça
c'est extrêmement compliqué quand vous
aviez ni votre casque de réalité
virtuelle vous vous êtes retrouvé
nina la peur s'est retrouvé vous c'est
lui qui a fait la même chose mais de
l'autre côté
alors c'est comme ça que on peut
communiquer avec les gens parce que on
se met à leur place
non ce n'est pas de l'empathie parce
qu'on ressent pas mais on essaye
finalement pour faire une communication
de voir ce que l'autre comprend de se
positionner par rapport à lui de
connaître ses capacités et ce comme ça
finalement qu'on peut communiquer
vraiment alors le dernier les facile
parce qu'il n'y a plus qu'une image on
ordures en rajouter une grille c'est
vrai mais on va faire comme si j'en
avais plein alors le transport le
transport automatisé exige des capacités
de perception des décisions complexes
parce que ça bouge partout ça bouge vite
autour il ya des obstacles et des
voitures alors c'est assez maîtrisée sur
les autoroutes
pourquoi parce que tout le monde bouge
dans le même sens à peu près à la même
vitesse
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué au centre
ville sur ces où je veux pas dire enfin
surtout à toulouse par exemple
à paris aussi où se trouve donc des
vélos des trottinettes des piétons c'est
très difficile à prévoir
et donc c'est quel robot que vous avez
vu que la machine
les voitures les peintures de compiègne
ils sont les voitures a conduite
automatisée et qui sont capables donc de
se déplacer d'elle-même avec ses
fonctions automatisées sur les routes
bien bravo mais bon un tableau agen les
beaux magnifique on a vu beaucoup de
choses on a vu beaucoup de choses et
c'est surtout chaque robot en fait ce
pari qu'on peut appliquer à la robotique
je me doutais même pas du centième de ce
que j'allais découvrir et je suis
vraiment émerveillé par tout ce que j'ai
pu mais du coup ça sourit aussi d'autres
questions
alors assez long elle et je m'assois
après avoir couru bruit et montez les
escaliers
voilà vous avez des questions oui bon
c'est vrai qu'en regardant tout ça avec
du recul on se pose une question qui
revient aussi souvent est-ce qu'il faut
avoir peur de ces robots alors les
robots qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce
qu'on a vu qu'est ce qu'on a vu toutes
ces machines
qu'est ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
arrêter ils ont beaucoup de limitations
mais on peut imaginer qu'on va les
améliorer mais on les améliore pour
faire quelque chose
à chaque fois il y a un objectif
transporter des charges lourdes dans des
endroits éloignés transporter des
personnes réparer en effet dans des
objectifs qui sont les objectifs qui
nous amène or la vie qui nous permettent
de nous fatiguer moi de retrouver des
capacités qu'on a perdu et c est cette
technologie c'est une science parce
qu'il faut bien à concevoir tout cela et
peut comprendre cette technologie et les
fêtes pour nous améliorer
effectivement l'existence mais les fait
partie et les fêtes par les êtres
humains fait par nous et les fait pas
d'autres
peleg et les industrialiser et les
revendus donc si un jour on veut
utiliser cette technologie pour faire
des choses qui ne sont pas forcément
disons le bien ça devient dangereux
medhat le danger ne vient pas des robots
il vient de personnes des humains qui
les utilisent mal
ce ne sont pas les robes ou de danger
c'est toujours l'être humain qui décide
ce qu'il va en faire alors on peut se
demander mais par exemple la vue de la
voiture autonome
est-ce qu'elle va prendre la place des
conducteurs alors qu'elle est
normalement fait pour réduire les
accidents de la route
donc évidemment on peut penser que ça va
réduire les conducteurs mais aussi ceux
dans la profession de conduire mais
l'invention de nouveaux
et de la nouvelle technologie crée aussi
de nouvelles opportunités de nouvelles
de nouveaux emplois et c'est comme ça
que finalement la société progresse
ce sont des compagnons qui sont là pour
nous aider à accomplir certaines tâches
et finalement la notion de peur ça n'a
rien à voir avec le ca c est finalement
l'éthique des êtres humains qui
conçoivent ces robots qui les utilisent
c'est ça qui est important
comme ils sont très souvent humanoïdes
pour die presse que c'était personnes
mais pas du tout les outils c'est des
outils sophistiqués sophistiqué de
l'intelligence artificielle séparé mais
ce qu'il faut en avoir pas et bien
l'intelligence artificielle en fait vous
l'avez déjà vu parce que toutes ses
capacités que vous avez vues dans les
différents robots c'est de
l'intelligence notre intelligence par
exemple nous c'est l'intelligence de
notre capacité à contrôler notre corps
dans un monde mouvant
inconnu qu'on explore comme vous avez
exploré ça c'est votre intelligence les
robots ils ont cette intelligence là ils
ont aussi l'intelligence de la décision
de la planification et l'intelligence
artificielle dont on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est des systèmes de
traitement de données des traitements
statistiques pour essayer de nous
humains faire sens de ces données et on
utilise donc des programmes
informatiques qui sont des programmes
dits d'intelligence artificielle qui
nous permettent de mieux comprendre
finalement ces données là aussi c'est
des outils sophistiqués pour
l'intelligence artificielle disons
logiciel c'est c'est quelque chose qui
traitent des données qui nous permet de
faire sens
l'intelligence artificielle des robots
c'est pour permettre à ces machines
matériel de faire des choses dans le
monde réel et il n'y a pas plus à avoir
peur de l'une et de l'autre
mais ces technologies peuvent être
utilisés d'une manière qui est mon
approprié exemption traitent des données
biaisées si on extrait des informations
et qu'on les utilise pour manipuler les
gens c'est là que le problème se trouve
à la beauty est une chose est celui que
le met en oeuvre
c'est lui qui porte la responsabilité
c'est en ce moment pour se défier
beaucoup dans les fonds axa la fin de la
vague marine roubaud oui je veux
repartir avec tout ce qu'ils étaient
trop bien j'ai pas eu peur une seconde
en tout cas bien au contraire j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait des perspectives
incroyable lily qu'est ce que t'en as
pensé de cette aventure et surtout à toi
bon j'ai adoré oui c'était trop bien la
fin des jours gfr alors venez nous
partager peut-être les dernières
instructions enfin un dernier mot pour
nous téléspectateurs comme en mai
mais où est ce que je suis un gars nuit
mon amie virginie merci pour cette
aventure incroyable merci de nous avoir
suivis de m'avoir aidé aussi parce que
parfois je sèche un petit peu donc
c'était bien de vous savoir à mes côtés
merci les lits pour ce défi et il voit
là je suis trop contente j'ai mon petit
robot j'ai appris plein de choses merci
et oui est vraiment bravo à toi merci
beaucoup pour cette belle aventure mari
et on se retrouve sur s2 science très
pur ne chasse pas et je rappelle aussi à
nos internautes que nous étions avec
combine techno pour ce live
restez connectés car nos modérateurs
roboticiens continuer à vous répondre
et si comme marie vous souhaitez gagner
une clé usb gros bras et obtenez vos
prêts est prête à répondre par mail aux
trois poursuivantes
et moi je vous embrasse et vous dit à la
prochaine
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]